continuing on the sentencing phase just
wrapped up for the day for the box truck
driver who killed five cyclists in
december right near searchlight
45 year old jordan varsity admitted he
was under the influence
of methamphetamine when he ran into a
group of cyclists
on u.s 95. joe mohler was in the
courtroom where relatives of victims
shared their struggles without their
loved ones
brian it was an emotional day in court
today we heard of from some of the
family of the victims and the accused
jordan barson
back in april barson entered a plea
agreement reducing the number of charges
he was facing to two counts of dui
resulting in death
family of some of the victims described
how the sudden deaths of their loved
ones changed their lives
douglas murray the brother of michael
murray looked at barson expressing his
loss you can also see barson's reaction
jordan barson
there are no words there are no words
to express what you've done to our
family
what you did to my brother i can't
imagine him laying out there in the
road looking at the carnage
that this man created
at the start of the sentencing hearing
barson stood up via video and said he
was sorry and that
he was ashamed with himself he says
after he gets out of prison he wants to
share his story at rehab facilities
prevent another tragedy
like this now barson faces up to 40
years in jail
we will hear from more family members
when the sentencing continues tomorrow
reporting live outside the courthouse
joe mohler 8 news now